this is a production of cornell
university
hi this is frank russey for the cornell
turf grass video log
and we're here in the heat of the summer
and we're starting to see some of the
problems that start to emerge especially
after a historically wet springtime
not a lot of root growth ideal
conditions for root pathogen development
especially infection of small
fibrous root systems by summer patch
organisms by take
all patch organisms by pythium root rot
organisms pythium root malady organisms
and so now as we start to get into the
dry period we start to see
the conditions under which if we were
not under stress conditions we wouldn't
see so because we're getting some
moisture stress because we're getting
some heat stress
we've got compromised root systems even
if you've got your protection down
you do your spring drench for the summer
patch or you do some manganese
applications for take all
or you've done some pythium control
materials you're still going to see
these patch diseases emerging
as the stress starts to build and so you
can try to make some curative
applications
they're probably not going to be as
effective and so what you want to do is
work to alleviate that stress
to help those plants limp through the
rest of the season with a compromised
root system
in hopes that over time in the next six
to eight weeks
things will recover and especially in
your fairway and collar turf where this
has become a problem
this is frank rossi for the cornell turf
grass video log
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu